mercredi 23 février après une séance
d'entraînement direction but que pour
les joueurs et le staff versailles et
les demi finalistes de la coupe de
france sont invités par ce magasin dans
le cadre de l'opération petit poucet ils
se sont vus remettre des maillots et des
écharpes devant plusieurs dizaines de
supporters
les événements ont ensuite pu approcher
le fameux trophée de la coupe de france
c'est un plaisir de voir cette coupe
présente sachant que la coupe de france
marc présente tellement de choses pour
les français cette proximité avec les
gens des valeurs de solidarité donc
c'est pour ça que c'est plaisant et
conçoit aujourd'hui ici ça ça fait
plaisir à nos joueurs et à tout club le
lendemain retour à l'entraînement pour
une séance classique avec quelques
invités des caméras et des journalistes
venus de france et de l'étranger sont
présents pour cette journée médias
l'occasion pour les joueurs de mesurer
l'ampleur de l'événement et avaya de la
ferveur qui propagent autour de nous et
franchement ça nous donne encore plus
d'énergie positive pour pouvoir gagner
ce match pour pouvoir aller au moins au
bout de la coupe quoi samedi dimanche à
deux jours de leur demi finale face à
nice le petit poucet binois s'est
préparée sur les terres de l'équipe de
france grâce à l'un de leurs sponsors au
centre technique national de
clairefontaine par container fontaine
c'est le repère de l'équipe de france et
c'est quand on est petit on voyait
envoyé une star ici et là le fait d'être
là les fêtes dans le château dans les
chambres des joueurs c'est la
préparation elle est parfaite on l'avait
déjà fait avant le match de toulouse ça
nous a apporté ses fruits ac 1 du
mythique pour le football français quand
on regarde et à la claire fontaine ou
d'autres reportages ou même que tu quand
on sait que tous les joueurs de l'équipe
de france jeunes ou adultes se
regroupent ici et que nous on a la
chance de profiter de ces installations
c'est magnifique l'occasion également de
voir une dernière fois leurs supporters
ils sont venus en nombre pour ce dernier
entraînement des versailles dans les
yvelines
le parcours qu'ils ont fait c'est sûr
que m c'est bien de venir les soutenir
battu une équipe de ligue 2 qui t'a
sainement égale manoir cette loi ils ont
eux su se battre est arrivé jusque là je
pense que contre nice les peuvent
continuer leur parcours au pass 2 jours
d'un seul coup on est mieux comme ça en
exergue franchement c c'est bien pour le
club c'est bien pour la ville aussi
quand ça connu pour autre chose que pour
château quoi donc c'est bien c'est bien
pour les gens du club pour les bénévoles
pour les joueurs pour le stage s'est
bien pour
pour la coupe de france c'est important
aussi des fois que le petit poucet qui
passe cailloux sur quoi je contemple un
plaisir plein de bonheur de pouvoir
partager ça avec et c'est pour ça aussi
que qu'on joue au foot pour partager des
émotions comme ça c'est énorme plaisir
en erreur en tentant d acné ultra
motivés mais les entends de se le dise à
se lever le matin venir il fait pas très
chaud bon il ya un petit peu de soleil
n'est ce pas très chaud mais venir nous
encourager comme ça pendant toute la
séance nous on sent que pour eux c'est
très important et franchement comme je
dis ça nous donne de la force à me donne
envie de nous surpasser déjà pour nous
et pour eux encore plus donc ouais
franchement pour nous c'est super
important les jouets en verser se sont
ensuite envolés pour nice dans la soirée
de dimanche pour préparer au mieux le
rendez vous une nouvelle semaine
historique pour le club et les yvelines